it's happened to everybody you decide to
open 10 cases and you get a purple mag
7. this is unlucky do it again now
imagine opening 92 000 cases
yeah now if you're a master math wizard
like myself that's about 230 thousand
dollars worth of keys and more if he
bought the cases himself and finding the
time to open 92 000 cases is already
pretty
impressive that's
1516 hours if he's opening one case a
minute and 63 days total if he's just
opening them 24 7 which obviously he
wasn't i mean i i hope he wasn't i hope
he's okay with that kind of money you
can easily afford a lamborghini huracan
or a mercedes g wagon or maybe a grand
piano or a shelby mustang pool table
or i don't know some nft